le premier président du tout nouveau csm
et avec nos bonjour patrick
lecurieux-durival bonjour monsieur vie
dont le csm c'est le conseil économique
social environnemental de la culture et
de l'éducation de martinique on aurait
même pu ajouter et du sport le 16e
patrick lecurieux-durival qu' une fusion
celle du conseil économique social
régional environnemental régional et du
cc un conseil de la culture de
l'éducation de l'environnement
pourquoi cette fusion aujourd'hui ce de
ces deux instances consultatives
j'ai presque envie de vous dire s'il y
avait pas eu la fusion souhaitée
surprenant puisqu'il ya eu dans un
premier temps une fusion entre le
conseil général et le conseil régional
et en toute logique les deux conseils
consultatifs si on était amené à
fusionner pour former une seule entité
donc on va fusionner par souci
d'efficacité de logiques politiques
d'efficacité de rationalisation des
moyens je dirais surtout par souci
d'efficacité et de meilleures
utilisations financière alors deux
instances de prestige qui fusionne
désormais une mais bon si c'est un césar
auparavant système aujourd'hui pour
faire quoi exactement
alors notre les missions qui sont les
nôtres sont prévues dans les textes dans
la réglementation dans la loi donc notre
mission c'est de donner notre avis à la
ctm chaque fois qu'elle doit prendre des
délibérations
alors ce ne sont que des avis vous me
direz et c'est vrai mais nous avons
aussi la capacité de nous auto saisir
ouais donc notre
conseil consultatif pourra sur certains
thèmes se saisir mener des analyses
faire des propositions et transmettre
ses propositions à la ctm mais nous
pouvons aussi informé grand public de
nos travaux alors pourquoi ne faut-il
pas sourire lorsqu'on vous entend
répondre lorsqu'on sait que le cce
auparavant le ceser hier elle le ccem
aujourd'hui mais c'est avis consultatif
finalement est-ce qu'ils sont pris en
compte ces avis pas toujours pas
toujours pour être tout à fait quasiment
jamais quasiment jamais ben non je me
tiens pas toujours parce que l'année
dernière en 2017
il m'a imeda et v de constater que
certaines décisions de la ctm reprenait
en fait des avis ancien du co2 la cce
émis plusieurs mois ou plusieurs années
auparavant donc ça peut vouloir dire qu'
un cheminement qui se fait et puis
aujourd'hui nous avons une chance et que
nous avons 65 membres au sein de notre
équipe ce sont 65 spécialistes 65 pour
présenter sa situation sportive
culturelle de l'environnement a fait
avec leur expertise avec leurs
connaissances et toujours leur volonté
de d'apporter leur contribution commence
on choisit ses membres alors ils sont
désignés au sein de chaque roue de
chaque organisation suivant des modes
assez différent donc il n'ya pas de
règle établie
il y aura donc deux commissions au saut
au sein de ce csm ordi csm ou 6e sem seo
sem est bon pour l'instant on cherche
l'appellation art de commissions une en
charge deux sections de section une en
charge de l'économique du social
l'environnement et l'autre de la culture
de l'éducation et du sport
oui en fait on retrouve les deux anciens
conseils consultatifs
à travers ces deux sections mais sur
l'ensemble de ces deux sections
il y aura des commissions qui vont elles
travailler de façon transversale alors
ce csm pour l'instant n'est pas encore
totalement installée puisque votre
élection patrick lecurieux-durival a eu
lieu en fin de semaine dernière jeudi
et vous allez terminer cette
installation mercredi tout à fait
mercredi nous allons nous réunir à
nouveau pour finir l'installation et
mettre en place le bureau donc les huit
membres qui constituent le bureau de
cette structure
et puis la constitution des commissions
et après vous allez vous vous retrouver
pour déterminer qui se rêvait thèmes sur
lesquels vous allez travailler
prioritairement ou bien vous allez
attendre tout simplement que les élus
vous demande votre avis il y aura les
deux en même temps nous allons nous
réunir donc là ce mercredi pour
finaliser l'installation
du csm nous allons vraisemblablement
nous retrouver la semaine prochaine pour
mettre en place les commissions avec
lesquels nous allons travailler et une
fois les commissions installées nous
allons commencer à travailler alors il y
aura les deux il y aura certainement des
velléités de se saisir de certains
thèmes
ah oui parce que lorsqu'on est au
pouvoir lorsqu'on est assis autour de la
même table et qu'on représente 3 la
culture soit l'éducation soit le sport
sur le social soit l'environnement
chacun peut être envie de de retirer
petit pull à col et la couverture sur
soi oui ça peut être une réaction
j'espère que on aura tous le réflexe
autres qui consiste à apporter sa
contribution de façon complémentaire
pour enrichir le débat
et puis il ya déjà des sujets sur
lesquels nous allons devoir donner
rapidement notre avis à la ctm notamment
le budget qui arrive bientôt
vous avez déjà quelques idées auxquelles
vous attendez nous sommes un singe
attend pour l'instant j'attends d'avoir
le budget sous les yeux pour avoir des
idées plus précises
alors patrick lecurieux durival indien
vous êtes là pour émettre des avis au
pour vous saisir de certains dossiers
vous n'allez pas attendre tout
simplement qu'il est plénière à
l'assemblée de martinique pour y mettre
cet avis est ce que le csm par exemple
peut décider de s'adresser directement à
la population sur tel ou tel thème
on pourrait le faire par correction
vis-à-vis de la ctm parce que je
souhaite que notre conseil consultatif
travail un bonne collaboration avec la
ctm quelle que soit son orientation et
sa sensibilité
nous sommes une structure amené à
travailler avec la ctm donc nous allons
travailler avec la ctm je tiens à ce que
ce soit des échanges fructueux
nous allons de toute les façons informé
la ctm de toutes nos réflexions avant de
les diffuser
est ce qu'en tant que président vous
n'avez pas vu venir tel ou tel membre
d'une certaine neutralité qu'il faudra
observer parce qu'on connaît un petit
peu les casquettes politiques des uns et
des autres qui composent cette cci seine
le très vite et je sais pas si c'est les
termes en tout cas moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que nous puissions
travailler de façon très factuelle sur
des thèmes donnés sans esprit partisan
qui pourrait réduire considérablement
l'impact et l'efficacité de nos avis et
nous le nom des avis qui serait perçu
comme des avis partisans il ya fort à
parier que personne ne nous écoutera est
ce que c est celle par exemple peut être
l'objet de pression sur les instances
politiques qui vote qui décide qui
choisissent les orientations pour le
pays pressions politiques non je ne
pense pas organe de suggestions de force
de suggestion et d'incitation
certainement le rôle de ces essais mais
de porter la voix de toutes les
instances qui la composent tout est tout
à fait nous avons une
une composition qui représentent
l'ensemble la quasi totalité de la
société civile de la martinique
donc oui il faut il faut écouter tout le
monde
alors alors tout à l'heure on attend on
l'a dit un il y à il y a deux instances
bien bien distinctes l'une composée d'un
économique social et environnement et
l'autre culture éducation et sport
vous n'êtes pas là pour un mandat de 6
ans 1 à mi parcours il y aura un
renouvellement tout à fait dans les
textes il est prévu qu'au bout de trois
ans il ya une alternance entre la
section économique et la section culture
je viens de la section économique donc
je vais devoir céder ma place à
quelqu'un qui sera dans la section
culture concernant encore ce csm est ce
que vous estimez aujourd'hui qu'il ya un
énorme travail à faire en terme de
communication pour que le grand public
sache à quoi exactement vos séries tout
à fait je pense que nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment connus pourtant nous
représentons une potentielle richesse
dans la réflexion et dans les
propositions au service de la martinique
il faudrait que ce soit de plus en plus
mieux perçue est de plus en plus connu
car comment faire justement sur cet
aspect des choses qui sont indiqués en
général les instances consultatives sont
un peu parquet un petit peu a observé à
doite de deux présidents d'assemblée un
peu dans le fond là comment on va faire
pour se faire voir davantage ou quoi
doit du président à côté du président
non
il va falloir communiqué il va falloir
apprendre à travailler différemment
peut-être que ça peut être l'occasion
vous aurez les moyens de cette cette
politique là j'essaierai de les avoir
une période où les budgets sont
injustement plus réduit mais j'espère
que nous les aurons il n'y a pas de
raison en tout cas c'est la cause que je
vais défendre auprès du président de la
ctm et vous aurez une oreille attentive
vous penserez à ce niveau là sachant la
suite vous dira ce qui ne ce qu'il en
sera pour l'instant on ne peut pas
présager
mais je ne vois pas pour quelles raisons
ils nous diraient non merci d'avoir été
ce matin avec nos patrick
lecurieux-durival rappelle que vous êtes
président du tout nouveau csm depuis
jeudi dernier le csm
c'est le conseil économique social
environnemental de la culture et de
l'éducation de martinique on aurait dû
on aurait pu ajouter et du sport merci
monsieur le recteur merci bonne journée
[Musique]